翻訳: Kayoko Shiomi
校正: Ichi Kanaya
「日本に、京都があってよかった。」
京都の魅力を発信するフレーズです
同様のフレーズが ＪＲ東海さんの
「そうだ京都、行こう。」がございます
二つのフレーズに共通する特徴
目的も何の説明もない
それでいて
多くの人の共感をいただいております
「なんで？」「何しに？」
そんな疑問はありません
クレームもない
いや 一回だけクレームがありました
姉妹都市交流でボストンに行った時
言いました
すると ジャパンソサエティの理事長
現地の人が
「門川市長 遠慮するな
世界に京都があってよかったと言え」
「私たちは そう思っている」
これ１回
そんな京都 その京都に生まれ
育てていただき
市長就任８年
現地現場主義に徹し
京都の歴史力 創造力に
それを支える人々の人間力に
感激しながら
皆のために駆け回っています
世界歴史都市連盟
108の歴史都市が加盟する
その会長を 京都市長が30年
一貫して務めています
世界に歴史都市は多いですが
100万人を超える規模の都市で
千年を超えて 都市の営みが
文化が 一度も遮断されてない
そんな 京都のようなまちは
世界できわめてめずらしい
と言われています
なぜか?
ここでは二つ説明したいと思います
一つは 京都の
「精神文化」と「ものづくり」
これが見事に融合し
伝統を生かしながら創造してきた
千年前に 源氏物語が書かれました
能 ・狂言 ・歌舞伎
さらに
茶道 ・華道・ 香りの香道
和食も京都で育まれ
発展しました
その背景は
自然との共生の思想であり
宗教 宗教的情操であります
そして それらがものづくり
織物・ 染め物 ・陶磁器 ・お酒
印刷 ・庭園 ・建物
さまざまなものづくりを
発展させました
そして そこに素晴らしい匠の技が
感性が 文化が発展しました
自らを律しつつ
豊かな暮らしを実現していく
これが京都であり
また日本であります
そのすばらしい伝統から
今 世界的な産業が発展しています
京焼・清水焼から「京セラ」が
仏具から「島津製作所」が
あるいは お酒からお薬
バイオテクノロジー
さらに 花札がゲーム機「任天堂」へ
大学のまち 知恵産業のまち
どんどんイノベーションを起こしていく
これが京都であります
もう一つ なぜ千年続いたか?
これは まちづくりのコンセプト
1,200年前 京都に都ができるまで
都の名前は
例えば長岡京 藤原京など
土地の名前などでした
しかし 京都は
「平和 ・安心・ 安全 ・安寧」を願って
都の名前に「平安」を刻みました
「平安」がコンセプト
そして 世界の歴史都市は
城壁で囲まれるのが常識でした
かつて 全部城壁がありました
しかし 平安京には城壁はありません
千年前から 都の外と中を分けない
世界の方々と交流する
文化交流
これが京都のコンセプトであります
「世界文化自由都市」を
京都は都市の最高の理想にしています
この千年前のコンセプトを大事にしたい
今 世界で争いが絶えない
貧困 ・格差・ 環境破壊
これらの課題を解決していく
その思想が京都にある
私はそう確信します
さて そんな京都
日本に 深刻な危機がございます
人口急減であります
日本人が経験したことのない
人口急減である
そのように言われています
その通りです
しかし 京都は150年前に経験しました
明治維新
都の地位を失った時に
京都は一気に
人口30万人から20万人に激減しました
都市存亡の危機であります
その時に 先人たちは何をされたか?
子供さえしっかりと育てれば
未来は明るい
「まちづくりは人づくりから」
であります
まだ身分性の色濃く残る
厳しい差別の時代に
地域の子どもは
地域の宝として育てよう
人々が まだ文部省がない時代に
お金を出し合って
64の地域制の学校を創られ
差別のない教育を始められました
そして 日本で最初の芸術大学も
創られました
これが今に続きます
人を育てることと
文化を大事にすること
そしてまた 京都にも日本にも
危機がございました
二十数年前の
バブル経済の崩壊であります
深刻な不況でありました
その時に京都は 市民ぐるみで議論し
長期ビジョン・基本構想を作りました
多くの都市の基本構想の冒頭は
都市のインフラをどうするか
産業政策をどうするか
しかし 京都は「京都市民の生き方」
これを大事にしよう
具体的には 京都市民の６つの得意技を
皆で議論して確認しました
「めきき」本物を見抜く批評眼
「たくみ」精緻なものづくりの技巧
「きわめ」何ごとも徹底して研ぎ澄ます
ええかげんな妥協をしない
そして「こころみ」新たな挑戦
さらには 「おもてなし」
そして「しまつ （もったいない）」
この心を大事にして
生き方を大事にして
具体的な政策に落とし込む
今 市民ぐるみで取り組んでいます
当時 不況から脱出するために
日本中で規制緩和の大合唱でした
どんどんと高層ビルを建てる
しかし京都は 決して小さな東京に
ならない覚悟を決めました
そして まずは
新たな景観政策であります
建物の高さの規制を強化する
デザインを調和あるものにする
屋上や派手な看板は２万５千件
撤去していただきました
京都は一段と 美しくなりました
そして「京都議定書 」誕生の地
もったいない しまつの心
ごみを減らそう
42％ ピークから減り
５つあった清掃工場は３つになり
ごみ処理のためのコストは
年間106億円減りました
そして
車中心の社会から
人と公共交通中心のまちにしよう
ということでやりました
お陰さんで 20年前
京都にお越しになるお客さん
41.7％マイカーでした
去年9.9％
４分の１以下になりました
皆で 地下鉄 ・市バスに乗りましょう
利便性も向上させましょう
お客さんが増えて
経営も大きく改善しました
そして「おもてなし」観光政策
191の政策を実施し
「世界で一番行きたい都市」
２年連続 一位の
高い評価を得るにいたりました
さらに「ひと作り」は大事ということで
「子育て環境日本一」にしよう
２年連続「保育所待機児童ゼロ」
また 熱意あふれる教職員
それを応援いただく地域やPTAのお陰で
小学校・中学校・高校の教育も
大きく前進しました
そんな京都に住みたい
京都で子育てしたい
こういう方が増えてきました
嬉しいです
８年前 京都市から出ていく人の方が
3,600人多かったんですが
最近 この一年では3,250人
京都に来られる方のほうが増えました
しかし 合計特殊出生率はまだ低い
なんとしてもこれを高めたい
京都で結ばれ
京都で赤ちゃん産んで
皆で応援して育てていく
そんな取り組みを
より一層強化したいと思っています
人口減少社会
これに挑戦するために
日本中で「まち・ひと・しごと」
創生の取り組みが始まりました
京都は
「こころ」を大事にしよう
「こころの創生」を真正面に掲げました
そして 市民力を生かす
市民の皆さんが 自分ごととして
皆ごととして取り組まれる
それを京都市がバックアップする
その総合戦略をいち早くまとめました
京都は 京都だけ元気になったらいい
そんなことは思ってませんし
全国の方々と心を一つにして
全国津々浦々の地方創生のモデルを
作っていきたい
こう考えております
笑顔を日本中に一杯にしたい
そういうことであります
「門川市長はいつも着物ですね」
そうおっしゃいます
そうです
ただ 誤解されているところもあります
京都のＰＲだけではないんです
今日は 着物は大島・羽織は結城
袴は仙台平です
日本で最も良い繭ができるのは
福島県の川俣
今も良い繭ができます
しかし 全国津々浦々の
地場産業は厳しい
東京一極集中
経済優先・効率化優先
そんな中で 日本の文化を支える
伝統産業が極めて危機的であります
私たちには大きな夢があります
京都から 千年続く
全国と繋がって
文化で ものづくりで
全国津々浦々を元気にしたい
地方創生に貢献したい
そして「京都を日本の文化の首都」に
更に「世界の文化首都」にしたい
こういうことであります
外国に行くと実感します
クールジャパンも人気であります
同時に 京都に伝わる
日本の生き方の哲学
暮らしの美学・寛容の精神
和の精神・宗教で対立しない
そうした哲学が
世界から尊敬を集めています
この時
日本人がそのことを再認識して
世界の人々の幸せのために
平和のために貢献できる
そのためにも
「日本に京都があってよかった」から
「世界に日本があってよかった
京都があってよかった」
そこへ高めて行きたい
そのためには「文化庁を京都に」
効率重視の東京から文化は
ちょっと距離を置いて
文化は京都で
そして千年に渡って
全国と繋がってきた心を繋ぎ
世界と心を繋ぎ
未来に繋いでいく
ハードルはございますけど
皆で一緒に「 文化庁を京都」に
そして文化で日本を元気にし
文化で世界の幸せ 人々の幸せに
世界の平和に貢献する
そのために 皆さんと一緒に
努力してまいりたいと思います
(拍手）